all right we are now live for another
dr. Sadler's philosophy pop ups this
time as viewers come in and start asking
their questions and making comments that
I'll respond to I'm going to start out
by talking about what's going to start
happening next week which is my
face-to-face academic classes
unfortunate in that I get to teach
everything that I'm teaching which is
five classes this semester all within
about a one-mile radius of where I live
so that is really lucky for me I'll be
teaching two classes at Marquette
University and two classes at Milwaukee
Institute of Art Design and then another
class at Milwaukee Area Technical
College so the Marquette and my ed
classes start next week I actually have
morning classes for Marquette two of the
same section the foundations in
philosophy class which is a new core
class essentially an intro class but
it's adding in a bit more ethics content
the way I'm teaching it there's a lot of
stuff on freedom and determinism and the
question of what is causality and then
it also has to teach them about
philosophical methodology and and find
some way to encourage and foster their
curiosity about the field of philosophy
so that's kind of a tall order to do in
a 15 week class but I've got it set up
but I'll tell you a little bit about you
know what we're gonna cover and and how
I'm planning on doing that and then at
my add I'm teaching this intro to
humanities class so it's not a straight
philosophy class as a matter of fact
it's focused on culture
intersectionality and the humanities we
have some required text for it and then
I get to add some text so I'll talk
about that in a moment and I'm teaching
a class that's new for me in some
respects and that is our class at my add
ethics for artists and designers I'm
really looking forward to that
and then at Milwaukee Area Technical
College which won't start next week but
will be the week after that I have an
intro to philosophy classes straight you
know intro class for quite a few of
these classes there's some mandated
requirements and that's not really that
big of an issue for me like the intro
class at at MATC they've got some topics
that I have to cover like you know Plato
and Aristotle on universals or Descartes
and Hume on skepticism and you know so a
lot of stuff along those lines so
that'll be interesting I haven't decided
for the intro to philosophy over there I
want to set it up sort of sequentially
chronologically or whether I want to do
it in terms of topics most likely topics
we have to do some metaphysics some
epistemology some moral theory and then
I'd like to smuggle in some philosophy
of language and philosophy of technology
as well so those that's sort of the big
picture of the classes that I've got
going on then
let me tell you a little bit about what
we're actually going to do so so the
foundations class is like I mentioned
there's a really strong emphasis running
through the entire semester on the will
freedom versus determinism and causality
so we're starting with some Plato that
way we get some Socratic methodology and
some platonic methodology and then we go
right into Aristotle and the Aristotle's
already going to get us involved with
that because we're looking at you know
for for causes and we're looking at the
discussions of human responsibility and
voluntary motion and then we're going
into Cicero will do on the ends books
one and three so we get some epicurean
and some stoic philosophy and then we're
gonna do Cicero's on fate which of
course has to do with freedom and
determinism as well and they're gonna
read a little bit of Lucretius on the
order of things or on the nature of
things rather
and Senecas letter 65 and then some
Epictetus and that takes us through the
ancient period then in the medieval
period we're doing some Augustine we're
doing some Ansem the ants um we're gonna
do pro slow jian and on freedom of
choice and then we'll also be doing some
all ghazali and some Thomas Aquinas and
then then we finish up with the medieval
area and then we're getting into the
modern period but we're kind of jumping
through that pretty quickly we're doing
three days on Descartes going through
all the meditations and a little bit of
the discourses or the discourse rather
and then we're doing some of Humes
inquiry regarding human understanding a
day on Wollstonecraft's a vindication of
the rights of women then some nietzsche
from beyond good and evil and we're
finishing up the semester with some hana
Arendt who I'm also providing as a
supplementary text to my students as
well
the my head class is the ethics for
designers and an artists we're doing
some straight out ethics stuff so
they're learning some moral theories but
then we also have to explore a lot of
questions about the nature of art and
design and their pop their function and
where there might be clashes between the
ethical and the demands of that and the
aesthetic so that should be quite
interesting I'm setting up making it
very case based we're beginning with the
recent Banksy painting that that
shredded itself as a case in every class
meets only once a week every class will
begin with a case study that we're going
to examine now as to the intro to
humanities class I see a sort of a
comment here that is either a joke or
kind of you know ideology by itself from
ghost intersectionality a euphemism for
nonsense and pure ideology that's period
ecology right there because it doesn't
just name that there there's a
legitimate thing
and we have to explore doesn't mean we
have to say that everything that's
mentioned is intersectionality is
automatically good but it's it's just
silly to to dismiss it like like that
especially if you're going to do it here
on my channel when I tell you that I'm
going to be teaching about it
kind of a dumb move I don't know why
you'd want to do that other than to try
to you know provoke a reaction and
there's the reaction so we will be doing
that there's going to be some discussion
of that but we begin the semester
actually by reading Sophocles Antigone
that's the the first text that we're
gonna go into and then we're looking at
that graphic novel persopolis we have
some other smaller readings about
research intersectionality the uses of
history and then us instructors are
invited to pick two texts or artifacts
or other things that we can have the
students engage with so they you know
it's it's a core class that all of the
freshmen have to take at my ad and
there's a lot of things that are already
sort of prescribed but we get to decide
what we're going to do I'll probably
think about shooting some videos on the
Antigone and if I have the time
depending on what I haven't actually
decided what other things I'm going to
use for those students because I'm in
the process of designing all five of
these classes as we speak I'm taking
time out of my day which should be spent
building syllabi and and class websites
and and finding resources and all that
to do this so I'm pretty busy right
right now with with that activity and
the reason I do that is this is the last
thing I'll say and then I'll jump into
questions and comments my view about
using course management systems that's
the websites that every college and
university now has for their classes is
that it's really important to give the
students a really high-quality class
website whether it's in Moodle
blackboard canvas d2l Sakai whatever
you're working with so that you can
provide them with a lot of resources
to help them make their way through the
you know the difficult readings and
texts that that we're going to work on
and also because it helps foster their
learning the more time they spend
engaging with the material the more the
learning is going to stick and the
better they're prepared for the class
sessions where you know we get our two
and a half hours a week with them so
it's very important that there a lot of
work goes in on the design end before
that rather than just being sort of
invented on the fly and quite a bit of
that for for me as I think all of you
know involves creating these lecture
videos the core concept videos that I've
been doing have been very helpful for
for many students and so I shot four
more core concept videos on Plato I just
got finished shooting a whole sequence
of core concept videos on Cicero's on
fate and later on today I'm going to be
shooting some on Aristotle's metaphysics
and then there's the you know there's a
lot of other things we're gonna shoot
some on decart's meditations Humes
inquiry I never got around to shooting
the ones on Wollstonecraft's am on
Nietzsche who else some more on Aquinas
some on Augustine's free choice of the
will so there's a lot of video
production work I need to to do alright
let's start taking some questions Maria
says I'm watching your news really
interested thanks for sharing your
knowledge well you're quite welcome I'm
wondering if metaphysics is only known
in the Aristotelian view well you've got
a wrist a fella Cole but I imagine
that's Aristotelian if there's more in
different ways of understanding it yeah
I mean Descartes is doing metaphysics
plato's doing metaphysics the Stoics
have a metaphysics which is is based on
a sort of materialist understanding of
things once we get to Christian authors
like Augustine and Anne Anne some we
have a different metaphysics at work so
we're going to be exploring a lot of
different metaphysical views we never
really get in any class we never really
get to explore the whole gamut of what's
available because
you're stuck with 15 weeks at best
sometimes less because you have holidays
that get in there so you're always
cutting out a lot of material but there
there's yeah there's all sorts of views
besides just the aristotelian 1jp fanboy
that design class sounds very
interesting I'm hoping that it will be I
will in fact be tracking you know some
of it's gonna be straight out ethics
theory but then we have to like I said
explore questions like well what is arts
purpose right so I would I would do
things that I might not do in an ethics
class otherwise like you know reading
say Tolstoy right his views on an art or
when I get to ethics of creativity will
bring in some Rilke and some Nietzsche
and some some other thinkers as well and
we have to try to figure out what is art
you know what counts as art and what
doesn't count as art because where we
draw those lines that's going to be
important in deciding you know how we
ought to approach these these objects so
they have any sort of call upon us you
know is it okay to do certain things but
not if they're works of art right those
are questions that we have to explore
all right daniel has a question for me
how do you approach the topic of gender
diversity of around students who think
gender is a function of only biology do
you have specific reading for this or do
you lecture your own idea is to start
well what I tell all my students in all
of my classes is you're gonna you're
going to be confronting ideas that you
disagree with because we're in any class
we're gonna study a whole range of
things that you couldn't possibly all
you know you couldn't agree to all of
them because you'd be insane if you did
even if we're just trying to like
ancient philosophy you can't be a plate
inist an Aristotelian and stoic and
epicurean yet skeptic all at once right
that's that's not possible
and when we get to things like the
nature of gender and sexuality yeah
we're gonna have some students who are
going to come in
and be convinced that there's only two
and that it's it's biological I can
steer them towards some of the
literature that's out there about you
know people who don't fit into that that
thing and we'll talk quite a bit about
how people conceptualize gender as well
and and I'm sure it'll be a major topic
of conversation I think that there's
some things already in the suggested
resources for the class that I can just
you know post and then I'll have them
read some other things as well all right
JP fanboy what is the favorite class
you've ever taught favorite class that's
a good question hmm you know when I was
the place where I actually taught the
widest range of classes when I was
teaching in the prison for Ball State I
taught at Indiana State Prison in their
four year degree program and I taught
something like 17 different classes I
mean I really like teaching ethics
classes but it was fun getting to teach
upper-level history of philosophy
classes as well and I always enjoyed
teaching some of the religion classes
that I taught to like religion and
American culture or we do sort of a
broad overview of that talk about a
class that's tough to pack all the
material into though that that really is
all right so I guess that's as close as
I can get favorite class I've never
taught brave jr. do you have any
recommendation on what philosophy to
check out after reading Plato and
Aristotle yeah I mean there's a lot of
people if you want to stick in the
ancient period and you want to do it
sort of sequentially you know you should
probably read what we've got of the you
know Epicurus which isn't much because
he's fairly close to them in time you
know you might also you probably should
read your way through day
arretez lives of the philosophers
because that introduces you to a lot of
these other schools couldn't hurt to
read some Xenophon who is you know
contemporary of plato fellow student of
Socrates definitely you should read the
Stoics and and you know you should read
Cicero too you should read your way
around in Cicero and Plutarch is
somebody quite important middle plate
inist and then you know there were just
sort of digging around you could say in
the the Hellenistic era there's so many
other people that you could go on to but
you know it's it's not as if you have to
do it in some sort of sequence
philosophy is an iterative process you
read so I'm you go back you do some more
you know so that's my recommendations
all right Maria has a follow-up
is there anything such as absolute truth
as Aquinas proclaimed as you know many
other people who proclaimed as well I
don't think I don't think Aquinas
actually uses the word absolute anywhere
that I've ever seen him writing and for
Aquinas you know what would be truth
with a capital T is what is in the
intellect of God which is very rare for
us to coincide with but he does think
that it that it's out there but sort of
many other people I mean so so does
Aristotle so does Plato so do the Stoics
so does Descartes all right question is
which of them are right about how we
should conceptualize it all right OSH
Mar in your latest blog post about
Epicurus you said you definitely aren't
an epicurean could you elaborate on why
because I think the Epicureans are wrong
about some fundamental things you know I
don't think that the good is pleasure I
think that pleasure is it good but I
don't think it's not good I'm more
astute Eliot in that sense that's that's
a really big one I also think that their
physical Theory what we have of it you
know although it's it's attractive to
some people because it has this atomist
you know beginning
it's not even remotely connected to the
atomism that that we rely upon in modern
science and you know I think the
epicurean tradition is quite interesting
and I teach Epicurus and and read
epicurus and lucretius and kasundi and
people along those lines but I you know
I just don't find a good portion of what
they teach to be all that convincing so
but you know you could say the same with
many other philosophers why am I not a
Hobbesian why am I not a Nietzschean all
right why am I not a conch in so
Abdullah is a far are there any
philosophical arguments that attempt
justifying eating animals yeah you can
find them in ancient times saying that
you know there's an order of being and
an animal being which is non rational is
therefore the rational beings
the Stoics thought that you know I think
the most of the plate nests seem to
bought into something like that
Aristotle seemed to have no problem with
that sort of thing so yeah you can you
can dig around and you'll find all sorts
of arguments that either justify
teaching animals or just simply take it
for granted as as a cultural constant
all right Kyle askin sister was
eclecticism for political systems be
used to blend other systems of thought I
don't know why you'd want to use
Cicero's eclecticism why not just use
eclecticism why tie it with Cicero and
you know when I think of Cicero's an
eclectic I don't think of it primarily
in a political sense I think of it in in
terms of his philosophy where he's
willing to draw upon the academic
skeptics on the Aristotelian zhan the
Stoics even every once in a while on the
Epicureans and you know bring them
together in some sort of coherent
synthesis but that's also what what the
Stoics did you know Zeno drew upon his
studies with krottas from the cynic
school and still pulled the Megerian
I'm blanking on the academic who he
studied with but you know he was fusing
things together and that's what
Aristotle does through his dialectic
method this is a very common thing I
mean maybe what you mean is is trying to
blend or mix together different regimes
you know like what Aristotle suggests in
in the politics that the best regime
would would somehow do justice to you
know some Oleg are kacal and some
democratic elements but also have the
elements of virtue built into it as well
Cicero you know is advocating something
like that but that's a very common motif
throughout history the mixed regime
right maybe that's that's what you have
in mind there and could it could it be
used to blend other political regimes
sometimes yes sometimes no I mean it's
not like you're gonna blend a a fascist
regime too well with something else or
some sort of you know Stalinist version
of Marxism with with something else you
kind of get that and then that it drowns
out everything else but you know a lot
of other things yeah you can blend them
together trick is to do it in such a way
that you get the the benefits of it
while reducing the the bad parts right
and oftentimes it happens with the
collect is's and is people wind up with
something that's kind of a mishmash
that's just giving us the worst stuff so
all right
Andreas just wanted to say I've been
finding your extended series on the
phenomenology very helpful thank you for
the hard work
well thanks I'm yeah I'd been at it for
now about five years I think and I still
have a lot yet to do on the
phenomenology of spirit but I'm getting
close to the end of the the spirit
section and then it's just religion and
absolute knowing so hopefully this
weekend I'm actually gonna get to shoot
some some Hegel video footage as well
all right Arvid I read philosophy as a
hobby if I start studying philosophy
seriously to fill my gaps of knowledge
I'm afraid that the introductory stuff
will war me how should I deal with this
skip the introductory stuff if you find
it bores you
then don't read the secondary literature
read the primary text first and then go
back if you find things are confusing
then check out secondary literature but
there's nothing that says you have to
get yourself an introductory
introduction to philosophy textbook and
and begin with that as a matter of fact
I don't even do that for my introduction
students I give them actual Plato to
read actual Aristotle an actual Cicero
that's part of why I develop all these
resources like like videos you know all
right Kyle was Luther correct when he
accused Aristotle denying the direct
serenity of God I imagine so it's been
years since I've read Luther so I you
know I can't really say but that does
sound like something I would say
right Luther who said reason as a [ __ ]
and I mean in the Aristotelian tradition
what we have a vet because Aristotle's
theology is pretty underdeveloped it
doesn't look like God does anything
directly right there's there's the
heavens and then there's all the stuff
that we do in the sublunar Airy realm so
it sounds it sounds about right
all right Charlotte operas which
philosophers writings would you say it
would be most focused on ethics there
isn't one single philosopher who you
could you could say is most focused on
ethics so I mean you can say somewhere
some of them didn't really have any
interest in ethics at all you can say
that but but many of the philosophers
who we study you know either they have a
work on it or parts of their work deal
with it even ones that you wouldn't
expect like say Rene Descartes the
passions of the soul and certain parts
of the meditations and discourses well
as the principles of philosophy what
would be pertaining to ethics which
makes sense because one of
key ideas behind des cartes whole
project was you know you get the
metaphysics right which leads to physics
which then has these these three
branches of Medicine mechanics and
morals so there should be you know a
Cartesian ethics clearly there's some
people like Aristotle or Mill or contour
are much more focused on ethics right
but it's not as if there's somebody
who's who's more who's the most focused
on ethics
Kyle how he was Heraclitus to bloody
post modernist no obviously not because
you know how could he be I mean we don't
even have that much of Heraclitus stuff
so anything that we could we could say
about his thought as a whole is
conjectural but I mean anytime
somebody's gonna bring up post-modernism
they got to say what they mean by it and
it's got to actually correspond to
somebody out there who's theorized about
post-modernism before I'm gonna take it
seriously because post-modernism isn't
just denying that you know there's some
sort of universal truth that there's
there's all sorts of other things that
that fit that that realm and and most of
the people by the way who are worked up
about post-modernism if they actually
like delved into the literature about it
they'd see they're actually post
modernists many of them are just as
deeply committed to this notion and they
may talk about universal truth but you
look at the way that they talk with
other people and behave they're really
post modernist when it comes down to it
they think that there is no there is no
master narrative that we all buy into
they're trying to force some narrative
and they they vary a lot of the people
who are complaining about post-modernism
have kind of a magical approach to logic
reason truth these sorts of buzzwords so
yeah all right let's see what else we
got here
Ken Roberts what are some rebuttals from
other philosophers for Vic and shines
thought that philosophy is pretty much
useless and we can't say anything
further in this realm you know you just
practice some philosophy and you can
figure out that he's wrong about that I
would say a lot of contemporary analytic
and some some continental philosophy is
pretty useless and there were other
things that back in the day you know
there's there's always a lot of non
entities in the philosophy world just
spouting stuff that is is popular at the
time which you know when you start
pushing it and trying to apply it turns
out to be kind of fine-spun BS but I
mean the notion that that somehow
Aristotle or Descartes or you know
Alistair McIntyre who by the way thinks
that Vicki Shannon is an important
philosopher that that all of what
they're doing is somehow useless because
Vidkun Stein wasn't able to find his way
out of the fly bottle it's kind of silly
it's kind of parochial I don't think I
don't think you actually need rebuttals
unless you're really really caught up
personally with Vic in Stein and you
know it's important to keep in mind big
concern did not read a lot of other
people in philosophy he's sort of an
outlier from the philosophical tradition
so just because he says something
doesn't mean we ought to automatically
or dogmatically say that it's true I
Daniel asks a tough question you said
before there are some objective moral
truths can you explain this a bit with
what methodology gives us an objective
moral truth is this available to all
rational creatures so I'll start with
the last part is is this methodology
available to all rational creatures in
theory yes in practice no and it's not
there isn't one methodology that we
would pick like oh I'm I found though
the right one and now everything falls
into place you you have to work at it
and things that you thought were you
know well articulated moral truths
sometimes require you to do a bit more
work right because reality is
complicated and moral reality is
complicated too especially when you're
dealing with human beings I again you
know this goes back to the eclecticism
thing
I adopt multiple approaches because I
think that while working on the same
basic human existence they provide us
with complementary perspectives there is
no one methodology that's going to give
you everything that you're looking for
in that respect but you don't have to
have a philosophical methodology in
order to do that there's plenty of
people who you know figure out on their
own that there are at least some
objective moral truths and what does it
mean to be an objective moral truth it
means that it holds across you know
individuals it holds across cultures it
holds from time to time you don't have
to have a you know everything is cast in
stone sort of viewpoint that in order to
get some mileage out of it all right
oswald spengler would be interesting the
real one here right love my video on
Heidegger's question concerning
technology wondering my thoughts and
other critics of tech in the same vein
such as Jacques Ellul Lewis Mumford and
Kaczynski I really haven't read any
mumford and I've never read Kaczynski's
manifesto I've read just like bits and
pieces of the little but it's been a
while so I you know I don't really have
that much to say about it I think you
know the high daguerreian insight isn't
unique
Gabrielle Marcel articulates many of the
same ideas as well about you know the
danger of as we called it man becoming
prey to his technics right meaning that
we we adopt a certain way of looking at
not just the world but but whatever
would be you know behind the world or or
what the world is comprised of that
turns things into what Heidegger is
calling standing reserve and that that
is a it's a problematic point of view I
think that Heidegger you know in in some
respects I don't know if Heidegger would
be effective enough for talking about
the is pervasive involvement of
Technology even
what we're doing right here you know but
he provides us with some good starting
points so yeah and when I mentioned
doing some philosophy of Technology in
my intro classes it'd be really really
basic stuff you know like what what is
technology to begin with you know how do
we how do we relate to it we're not
going to get in into a lot of high
theory I probably won't have them
reading Heidegger on the question
concerning technology because it's an
intro class and and we only have so much
time so all right
up north or I'm interested in knowing
whether you have a favorite work or a
work you'd recommend especially in the
field of linguistic philosophy I guess I
could say yes but it it would it would
be something that's in a certain respect
kind of on the the edges of philosophy
of language and it's more dealing with a
related field and that would be kind
Pearlman his new rhetoric I really
really like that work I mean other
people who I like on language I mean I
read Vick consign I think John wisdom is
important to take a look at of course
Nietzsche you know you need to check out
him and do so sir and a lot of these
other people who are coming out of dis
so sure and you know there's earlier
people but I'll mention some other
interesting people you know somebody who
I really do recommend when people start
getting into the philosophy of languages
they're Umberto Eco because he's great
yeah giving you summaries of what
different people are doing and then
giving you his own views on it paul
ricoeur really important as well I like
him quite a bit so alright Mike would
can you share your thoughts about advice
Vedanta it's a it's you know a tradition
or school of Indian philosophy that I
teach about sometimes but I don't buy
into it all
no I don't I don't any sort of monism is
not really a thing for me you know it's
interesting like so many other things
but I just you know it's not it's not
something that I take seriously enough
to spend a lot of time on alright
Michael Davis was thinking about writing
a commentary on shopping hard and most
commentaries deal with other secondary
texts when writing their own commentary
or deal directly with the primary text
that's a good question if it's dealing
primarily with secondary literature it's
not really a commentary on the text it's
a commentary on secondary literature
it's like a literature review right so
commentaries are commentaries on texts
you might want to take into account what
some important scholars say on things
particularly if your commentary is in
disagreement with them you know but that
would happen mostly like in footnotes I
think or in inside discussions if you're
commenting on a text you're trying to
explain what's going on there you're
trying to provide context or or you know
analogies or ways of understanding
things you're making connections between
what's going on in this part of the text
and where you know the author referenced
this idea somewhere else so yeah alright
Daniel Cox can you speak a bit about
what hermeneutics is why it's worth
studying and what its relevance is to
contemporary thought well if we're
talking about philosophical hermeneutics
as a movement then we're talking about
you know thinkers like Adam ER and
reeker and I would say hunter Arendt
kind of fits in there as well and
hermeneutics is fundamentally
interpretation right and its
interpretation of thinkers texts ideas
placing them in context trying to have
them speak in the present to us but
understanding the distance between where
they are and where we are
I'm trying to you know make them
relevant it also focuses a lot on the
very topic itself of interpretation of
you know whether what we're bringing to
the text in terms of you know
presuppositions or prejudices and yeah
so that that's you could say that's what
hermeneutics is now there's also you
know religious hermeneutics somebody
like Schleiermacher would be an
important theologian in that but when it
comes to philosophy you know if you look
at somebody like say God mer gadamer has
you know important works of his own like
truth and method but then he also does
all these studies like you know they get
six studies on Hegel he's got you know
stuff on Plato and he's interested in
trying to bring out what's really going
on in those texts and and make them
speak to a new epoch and generation now
why is it worth studying well wouldn't
you like to know how people do that sort
of thing or see examples of that I would
yeah I think it's important to do that
and I you know find people like recur
and Arendt definitely you know worth
learning from once it's relevant some
contemporary thought it may not have
relevance for some contemporary thought
as a matter of fact that's one of the
problems a lot of contemporary thought
so deracinated I mean it's you know you
get these these interpretations of
Descartes where you're like man this
person's never actually read anything
other than this little section that
they're they're talking about this what
they're reconstructing as Descartes
there's very little resemblance to what
he's doing or you know the why of what
he's doing
you know hermeneutics helps you restore
a sense of perspective and it's
dialogical you know and and philosophies
dialogical so Sarah Kemp what would
Socrates of
brexit I don't know probably just as
misguided as as most political
initiatives is what Socrates would
probably say you know he definitely want
there to be like a long conversation
about its its its merits and I think he
probably would have seen the the rush to
brexit and also some of the opposition
to brexit as based in demagoguery but
you know I don't know you'd have to you
know it's not like he he talked about
that particular issue
Artie Whitby did Plato believed people
who achieved a higher level of
excellence and life deserve to be
treated better yes and no deserve to be
treated better in some sense but in
other senses we should treat everybody
well I mean one of the things you see in
Plato is we shouldn't return evil for
evil right tough thing to live up to and
we should you know try to cultivate
everybody's humanity their their
rational aspect but you know should we
put everybody in charge
maybe if that's what you have in mind by
treating people equally no Plato Plato
thought democracy was a real mess hey
but so is oligarchy it's just you have
less less dummies running the show in
oligarchy than you do in democracy it's
not you know they're not any less
dummies so Tom eight have you ever been
in contact with God and certain of it
certainty has never been an issue that
I've been particularly captivated by
yeah I've been in contact with God but I
can't say an awful lot about that
because I think any contact with God is
going to be mediated and yeah I mean I I
think that if you want to come in like
Alistair McIntyre if you you know if you
want to come in contact with God I don't
know maybe go to Mass you know
like and you don't even have to take the
the Eucharist be like the medievals do
and just you know take a look at it
right sight is contact as well now you
might say well that's not much of a God
well you know then it's not going to
work for you it but yeah and and I don't
worry too much about issues of certainty
I'm more interested in issues of
richness of meaning so yeah I think I
think a lot of people place the cart
before the horse in terms of certainty
they you you can't actually attain
certainty about many things that matter
unless you've actually done a lot of
work to place yourself in the right
circumstances all right reading as
Sameer have you reading about Plato
seems that modern scholars are fairly
skeptical of his philosophy is he
respected only for setting the
foundation of the discipline or is he
worth more than that well I mean you're
kind of mixing some questions together
modern scholars respecting somebody is
not the the index of whether that person
is worth more than that right it could
be that the modern scholars are wrong
and maybe the plaintiffs are completely
right maybe it turns out that there
really are forms and that there is a
form of the good I mean lots of Jewish
and Christian and Muslim neoplatonist
have a word for that caught they call it
God it's actually some some pagan
neoplatonist to now a lot of modern
scholars are fairly skeptical of you
know things like the doctrine of
recollection or the doctrine of the
forms that's quite true but so were many
ancient philosophers Aristotle himself a
student of Plato thinks that the
doctrine of the forms is ultimately
incoherent but you know do we do we
study him just because he sets the
foundation of the discipline it does
more than set the foundation of the
discipline provides you with all sorts
of interesting explanations and
arguments and things that you know you
have to sort through on your own
and you know quite frankly a lot of the
modernist ministers of Plato have only
read a little bit of Plato so if you
want you know if you if you want to use
them as a guide you've got to figure out
just how much of they actually read and
taken seriously of Plato all right Andre
gamete Oh do I think I'll ever write a
book about my own philosophical views
that would be interesting um I might you
know it probably would not be like the
big book of Sandler's philosophical
views about everything because I'm not
sure I could even you know set all of
those down coherently let alone have the
time to do that but I'll you know I'll
certainly like put my views I'm sort of
like Aristotle right before we set out
our own views let's see what other
people had to say about it because maybe
they already came up with a good point
interview on it or maybe we can improve
upon what they do I'm a dialectical guy
in that that respect and and yeah you
can probably look forward to seeing at
least some books if I have the time you
write them where I set out some things
that I think you know are the case but
it'll probably come after like treating
a couple other people's things as well
all right Kyle currently reading Cicero
so wasn't too aware of eclecticism in
the broader context I totally thought
you were going to laugh at the
Heraclitus joke reference to Jordan
Peterson I don't know what Peterson said
about about Heraklion as if if anything
I mean if he thinks he's a postmodernist
he's really stretching the meaning of
the term yeah all right
Artie would be did Plato believed in the
practical implementation of the ideas in
the Republic we don't know it's a good
question
Platonists certainly wanted to he wanted
him at kallipolis Plato you know he did
have his chance in in Sicily trying to
influence one of the tyrants
but it didn't work and I mean I think I
think a lot of people view the ideas in
the Republic as sort of like one
possible sketch of how things would work
there is also of course the laws right
another longer and newer but written
when Plato is older dialogue as well and
that one gets into a bit more than
nitty-gritty of things so but there are
some things that would be kind of cool
to implement you wouldn't have to
implement every single aspect of the
Republic right you could you could take
on some parts of it all right McGill
Bennett says what works if you found
most helpful in the field of aesthetics
well I am NOT a specialist in aesthetics
so I don't usually I'm not you're not
gonna find me like reading a lot of
books that are just straight out
aesthetics
I'm usually encountering those ideas in
the context of other things so I don't
know I definitely I'd have to think that
through what what have I actually found
particularly useful or compelling
nothing nothing pops to mind right away
alright Sean says I heard you Fichte
mentioned Fichte before in your videos
getting your book tour you do not have
many of his texts I found Hegel so
called reputations of them unconvincing
what do you think I don't think victory
has to be ref refuted you know I mean
who says we have to refute anybody begin
with right we have to we have to refute
Fichte why don't we have to refute the
Stoics but why don't after we have to
refute Spinoza I mean you're why pick
that is the cornerstone that you're
gonna die on I mean 50 is pretty
formalistic clearly Hegel is drawing on
some of his ideas but going beyond him I
mean if there is a refutation it's in
having much richer content than what
Fichte provides and you know
in my book tour I didn't have many of
his texts there's plenty of people I
don't have many of their texts on my
book tour but I've read and studied I
wouldn't draw that that inference
I just never you know when I was a
graduate student I read through fixed I
never found him that really that
interesting quite frankly maybe if I
returned to him again if I find the time
I would have a different you know
revised point of view on him as a you
know middle-aged scholar now that's
happened with other thinkers who I've
developed a much greater appreciation
for but it's a matter of finding the
time and I I'm certainly not going to do
that this semester all right why I'm
gonna butcher your name Walczyk perhaps
you said that you you said in a that you
think college students aren't postmodern
and instead of emotivist do you think
this is a bad thing and you think it's a
peculiarity of our time I'll start with
the last part is it a peculiarity of our
time no motive ISM in the sense that
McIntyre and and some of the you know
writers like Stevenson who coined the
term mean it has been around for quite a
while
I mean Hume with with a few you know
exceptions is is essentially an
emotivist right Thomas Hobbes has
essentially a fairly emotivist
underpinning for what moral system he
puts together but emotivism in the sense
this unmoored like it's all just
preferences and desires and expressions
of that we're all just trying to
convince each other to see things new
things the way that we would like that's
that's more of a modern thing but it's
been around for quite a while it's not
this generation of college students my
generation of college students was like
that and I'm willing to bet the boomers
were too
now you know it's not as if postmodern
and emotivist are two totally separate
categories right
it's just when we use this word in
postmodern it's got to have reference to
something that's that's based in the
literature on it just like the word
fascist - if you want to call somebody a
fascist and you want me to not turn you
out it better have some reference to
something that actually looks like you
know classical fascism otherwise I think
you're full of crap and you and you
probably are just talking out of your
ear right
so you know you could be an emotivist
and be a post modernist but it takes
more than just being an emotivist
to be a post modernist and i and i think
there's plenty of people who talk the
talk of like universal truth and all
that but you look at the way that they
behave especially in social media and
you can you can tell they're a
postmodernist in the in the classic
sense ism of the term now do I think
emotivism is a bad thing yeah it is it
is a bad thing in that it stands in the
way of fuller development of human
rationality and a better moral
perspective it's not that bad per se
it's bad because of what it replaces and
supplements and stands in the way of the
way that so many other things are bad
there are some things that are bad you
know because they destroy the good right
emotivism in a certain respect rules out
the possibility of even understanding
what the good would be and and it it it
inculcates people in stultifying
I almost said stupid but stultifying is
a better way meaning making people
foolish ways of thinking about
themselves making cases to other people
it lowers the common denominator very
very far and it features people this is
all that that they can aspire to that's
a problem for me because there's there's
so much more I mean if you are reading
Aristotle as an emotivist
you say well the
are all just expressions of Aristotle's
own point of view and he'd like me to
live this way but there's really no
truth to it or anything like that if I
want to be an Aristotelian and it's just
because if you know I get kicks out a
bit you know well that's no way to live
you know you don't get very far with
that there are a lot of people who are
emotivist so it's good to diagnose that
but it's not it's not all there there is
right all right on has a follow-up about
Fichte I think victus should take a
bigger role in the Canon in history of
philosophy classes what do you think
yeah sure but so should Pascal and you
know so should Plutarch and so should so
many other people point is we don't have
the time or the space to cover everybody
so we make choices and Fichte wound up
on the short end of the stick I mean
Schopenhauer did for a long time too
although he's undergoing a kind of
Renaissance you know we all have our
people that we'd like to see get a
bigger role John Alexander would be
adding to your videos on Aquinas I'd
like to hear a breakdown question 84 the
Summa theologia which is the meat of
some mystic epistemology I don't think
there's anything that's the meat of too
mystic epistemology quite frankly the
the Summa is an incredibly complex
document and quite often in Aquinas he
never actually gives you his full thing
in the question where he's supposed to
be talking about it it's always in all
these other places listen you have to
piece together the theory right but yeah
will I be adding to my videos on Aquinas
I'm hoping to I'm hoping to shoot some
stuff on prima parse question two and
pretty much kunde question two and on
some other stuff as well for my students
but I'm shooting it for my students this
this semester and so you know I won't
get into too much of it there we go
Francis or Franck oh sorry what would
political philosophers say about the
government
shut down I think that they would want
to look at why the government has shut
down and they would want to look at why
are our American political system is in
such a dysfunctional state that a
government shutdown like the type that
we're having right now which is
affecting a lot of people a lot of
people are losing access to benefits we
actually don't have our insurance cards
right now because of the government
shutdown and you know we're gonna need
them so you know it's affecting a lot of
ordinary people they didn't want to know
why why is our society so screwed up why
is it so factionalized that we can't we
can't get things done even though we
have an incredible level of material
prosperity so I think that's where
they'd start let's see Cod moans Oh
heart ooh
when the Haegele marathon is done it
would be cool to put it on a DVD set
maybe salt with a Hegel text to read
along I don't think you could put it on
a DVD set because it would be like a you
know a giant stack right and and who
watches DVDs anymore I
it would take an incredibly long time to
to do that because there's you know
there's hundreds of hours of material so
I don't know that that's something I
would I would try to do Toby do you know
if there's any truth in Monty Python's
philosopher song about the Philosopher's
named being alcoholics or is it all just
made up for laughs it was pretty much
made up for laughs I mean a lot of
people like to to bring up Monty Python
sketches don't go to sketch comedy to
learn anything about philosophers
because it's almost always completely
off base you know yeah I mean they you
know they may have studied some some
philosophy but they're they're not
they're not in the business of
accurately depicting anything right all
right Darren and I'm getting close to
the end so I'm not sure I'll get to
everybody
things when you analyze existentialist
are you analyzing what they truly mean
are you analyzing whether or not what
they say is actually true
I refer mostly to Heidegger or heck even
hegel hegel is not an existentialist
Hegel is one of the people the
existentialist targeted that's being
like that guy that they're they're
opposing so I analyzed what they what
they mean what they truly mean we have
to sort of peel through layers you have
to actually understand the language you
have to know something about the
background you got to think about how
that would apply and and you know the
idea that you can somehow totally
disentangle what a a philosopher in a
prime philosophical text means from the
question of whether it's actually true
and like stripped them totally apart
from each other a lot of philosophical
assumptions built in there quite often
they're they're more closely connected
than that and sometimes you have to you
know you have to accept some of the the
ideas before you're even going to have a
unit even see over the horizon of what
they're trying to get at so but I you
know I also do think about whether what
they're saying is true or whether it's a
reflection of their own desires or it's
kind of [ __ ] or things like that but
you go back and forth it's not it's not
as if you do these as two totally
separate processes Artie Whitney did
Plato believed eugenics is virtuous no I
mean courage justice temperance you know
wisdom perhaps piety those are virtuous
because those are virtues eugenics could
be a means to an end in the platonic
republic but is it virtuous by itself no
and you know he'd probably look at a lot
of the people who are like fans of
eugenics and say wow those people are
nutters or you know they're driven by
their their passions or whatever you
know all right
a XX thoughts on reductive eliminative
materialism specifically claims by the
likes such as Dennett that consciousness
is an illusion i don't take them
seriously
I don't I don't really waste time on
them the notion that consciousness is
merely an illusion
you know who's actually saying that so a
meat machine who's not conscious at all
who's merely having an illusion of
consciousness you you start to see the
absurdity of these things pretty pretty
quickly alright John Ortiz so if I read
the crisis of European Sciences and
transcendental phenomenology by Edmund
Husserl if so would I think of that book
yeah I read it and you know it's it's uh
it's interesting it's probably one of
the most interesting of corrals books
who Cyril is not known for being a
captivating writer and it's been a long
time since I read it so I don't really
have much to say but I don't I don't I
don't spend much time with Worcester all
these days unfortunately but who Cyril I
always found reading Cristo kind of a
chore frankly all right Artie Whitby do
I believe Mary Wollstonecraft's quote
virtue can only flourish among equals is
correct yeah if you want virtue to
flourish in the full sense there has to
be a sort of equality but it's not a
leveling equality it's a bringing
everybody up equality and wolf stone
craft is just as hard on women as she
was on men for buying into you know
cultural systems that in effect gave
them trade OS of getting to be pretty
and and charming and not having to
develop themselves as moral persons and
I I think that that Wollstonecraft and I
think that Rilke are right in saying
that we're not quite finished when it
comes to the development of men and
women and that you know
a fuller sort of relationship which is
possessed by some people in in the
present and in their past but as
exceptions could someday become the norm
and that's part of what I hope for for
my my own you know children and students
and people coming after me I mean
someday either will will you know
descend back into some sort of barbarism
or just go into some cycle or will will
get to the point where like boy a lot of
this stuff where we've been you know
holding on to this [ __ ] and this
[ __ ] in this [ __ ] because it
satisfied some emotional need or
alleviated our anxiety about change or
you know it's you know stood in the way
of the profit motive I think someday
hopefully we'll get to the point where a
lot of those things are are beyond us
and we're like well there was a quirk
back then that they actually believed
that that's sort of nonsense and we're
willing to die for it and and you know
impose all sorts of things on each other
and damage each other for that I think
you know that's that's one of the
reasons I teach Wollstonecraft each term
in these philosophy classes all right
5:01 I'll take just a few other
questions that I can knock out pretty
quickly
20:46
seems like you're more interested in
socialist and fascist thinkers do you
give much credence the liberal thought
where do you consider liberal thought to
fit in the picture I don't know why you
would send more interested in social and
fascist thinkers you know I'm interested
in in political thought across the
spectrum and I don't know what you mean
by liberal either
there's classical liberal there's
liberal in the sense of progressivism
there's you know all sorts of stuff that
fits in there but I you know I read
pretty widely and and do I give much
credence to liberal thought I'm not a
party movement person for any sort of
you know thing like that I'm a virtue
ethicist so I'm gonna see problems both
the socialism and fascism and with you
know classical liberalism and with you
know contemporary liberal leftist
thought as well alright let's see here
mister
in your opinion who are some of the most
important contemporary philosophers
Alistair McIntyre is definitely somebody
we're gonna read centuries from now I'd
say Peter Singer pretty important you
know representative of the utilitarian
tradition there's a lot of great people
doing excellent work in the history of
philosophy and occasionally writing
their own stuff down like Julia honest
you know and you know we could go on and
on and on there's there's there's
contemporary thinkers who whose work I
enjoy like Giorgio Agamben but I don't
actually have the time to follow up with
like the whole gamut of contemporary
stuff so there's probably a lot of
people that are well worth reading that
I just never get to let's see what else
poopa Matt - who are the philosophers
you would consider to be geniuses I
don't even know what a genius should be
so I know I never really worry about
that and you know the whole notion of
genius I think has been kind of worn out
it was the same thing with people who
are like brag about their IQ you know
there was some interesting Twitter feeds
about this recently I mean I've known
people who have managed to like score
high on IQ tests at the time that they
took it and then you know but they're
they're jerks and they can't manage
their life while their relationships
well and you know I think it's much less
important to be like hyper intelligent
in that measurable cognitive sense and
it's much more important to actually
have a sense of perspective and be able
to figure out you know what to do after
you screwed up and you know how to set
things right and how to successfully run
your life in relation to other people so
alright here's a good here's a good
question to go out on especially since
I'll be doing one of my talks and
speculative fiction series tomorrow so
those of you if any of you are in the
Milwaukee area tomorrow night I'm going
to be doing a talk leading a discussion
really on Edgar Allan Poe and some
philosophical themes in his work by the
way Poe is somebody who actually did
read a lot of philosophy
so Callie Paulus are you interested in
possible worlds theory especially in
relation to your speculative fiction
series so I started I got introduced to
the the you know the like contemporary
possible worlds theory you know the day
of Lewis stuff back as a graduate
student it was actually like the first
class that I took in graduate school we
started out with with with that sort of
stuff
there was a metaphysics class taught by
Andrew black actually I take that back
we read a little bit of liveness a
little bit of Aristotle before that and
then jumped right into the you know
modal stuff and possible worlds things
and I thought it was pretty cool but you
know I never really stuck with that I
never saw it as being particularly
useful the possible world semantics
stuff I am very interested in the idea
as I do find in speculative fiction you
know like duplications of individuals or
different worlds that would somehow come
together as you know you might find like
in even Voight some of his stories it's
not really but possible world semantics
is not something that I used to make
sense out of necessity contingency
possibility impossibility I don't I
don't see a hell of a lot of utility in
it and it became kind of a fad for
awhile and I think that that also turned
me off on it as well Philip dick could
be another person right talking quite a
bit about different universes trying to
think of who else but so so the answer
is I I do know the possible world
semantic stuff but I don't really use it
much although I can I can talk the lingo
and follow what other people are writing
and then the
fiction I am interested in the ideas of
possibility necessity you know
contingency and possibility how what
makes an individual and individual all
these sort of metaphysical things but I
don't use the possible world semantics
to to figure that out so all right we're
a little bit over time and I have to get
to filming before I have to get to the
gym before I have to get back to work
before I have to get to bed so thanks
for all of your questions and comments
and we'll do another one of these on
Facebook you know Facebook live later on
this month you know they pop up same
topic but I'll be able to say something
about you know how my classes are going
at that time and you know you can look
for other online events that we've got
going
also look for some Aristotle content if
I if I get the work done that I'm
supposed to get done now that I got the
Plato Republic book six and seven stuff
finished so wherever you you are I have
a good good evening or good night or
good morning or afternoon and I'll see
you somewhere else in one of these other
events